acá está el equipo de ancelotti en el
mejor momento de la temporada sin duda
aquí si vemos un pico de rendimiento muy
interesante y mire es que el equipo de
ancelotti no tiene un planteamiento
táctico muy sofisticado ni muy complejo
pero está basado justamente en un
sistema muy sólido un sistema muy sólido
basado en los grandes rendimientos y
talentos individuales tanto en el
mediocampo como en la zona de delantera
benzema ahora aparece rodrigo como dos
fichas clave es un revulsivo y un
jugador como benzema que ya hemos
hablado aquí incontables veces lo que le
está aportando a este equipo ahora yo
creo que estás remontadas no sólo hablan
de un tema anímico o emocional como
siempre tiende a pensárselo esto de la
jerarquía del real madrid sino que
implica también un convencimiento en la
idea y en el convencimiento en un
entrenador que sin muchos aspavientos
creo que ha logrado un funcionamiento
interesante evidentemente en los
primeros 30 minutos hoy le costó
físicamente entró desconcentrado a este
partido frente a sevilla sevilla hizo
las cosas bien en esos minutos pero este
equipo está mostrando eso no que sin
mucho brillo si tiene jugadores muy
importantes y un sistema muy aceite